[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
thinks she has bipolar but maybe
not we also talked to a woman who is
struggling with her relationship with
food
and this is nuts we talked to a pastor
who asks me for advice on his preaching
series what stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john dolone's show
man look at this out here man there's a
million people in the lobby
i probably overstated that by
999
000 people or so
actually i overstate it by more than
that too
also um in additional to working on
people's mental health i'm also a
part-time mathematician i'm incredible
at it james is proud of me dude it's
good to see everybody out there man
everybody doing well
i know this sounds really annoying for
the podcast listener they're like i
don't know what you're talking about
what you're looking at anything but
anyway and the cameras are on y'all so i
hope y'all are all
not cheating on the person you're with
hope y'all are all dating each other
because otherwise it'd be weird yes good
to see everybody
hey so um this is the last show before i
take a break for a couple of days man it
won't the listener won't know but james
you won't have to see
i'm just saying that for you that's my
christmas gift to you it's pretty
awesome
even though this is what in february now
the show's coming out
just about january
and jenna
i'm gonna miss you
i appreciate that
that was awesome that's like the high
school kid that tells a girlfriend i
love you and she says thank you that was
awesome thanks for considering my
feelings jenna
appreciate that man she is like kelly jr
kelly equal there's no even junior
they're just equal all right let's go to
cece in sagin um
where are we here cece what's up cece
hi merry christmas john you know what
merry christmas to you too
thank you i cannot believe kelly deemed
me worthy i am here
hey
she has not deemed me worthy so
congratulations this is a big this is a
big thing this is jack for sure way to
go all right so what's up
well
two years ago i was diagnosed with
bipolar with mixed episodes
and since then i'm really trying to find
a way to protect my marriage and to
protect my daughter from the aspects of
the illness okay
so what's the best way to do that
got it let's fix it you ready
yeah
so let's i want to take the diagnostic
and just put it away for a while okay
okay tell me about your marriage and
your kids how long you've been married
all that stuff
okay so we got married in 2014
um and right away we started trying to
have kids um and it didn't happen
so for five years we were going through
fertility treatments
and that was really really rough his dad
died his sister died
so like we were dealing with trauma
after trauma
and then um we were super blessed to
have a daughter in 2019
and so she's two years old right now and
she's doing great
how long have you
wrestled with
some of the symptomologies
oh um i can remember the depression
reaching back into like high school for
sure
and my parents were definitely begging
me to like get help or like medication
and i was like no no it's just a season
i don't need this well
one season always ended up going into
another season into another season it
just got kind of deeper and deeper
so
i didn't really notice manic symptoms
until
after i had the baby
and i went
for help
for
postpartum and they recommended me to a
psychiatrist and a psychiatrist said
these hallucinations you're having these
interesting thoughts you're having
they're really not postpartum it's
bipolar
so that's how i ended up there
so will you do me a favor
nope you know what it's not even doing
me a favor
you and i are best friends for sure
but um
this favor is for you
okay for your kids and your
child and future kids to come if y'all
so
choose
for your
husband um i want you to go
talk to somebo some people in your
community
okay and find a good do you have a good
relationship with your ob gyn now
um
yeah pretty good yeah
is this is he or she
he yep did he is he the one who referred
you out to psychiatrist or did you meet
with him
um i met with
his
uh social worker at his office okay and
they referred me out okay i want you to
get a second opinion on that okay
okay
um
i'll just leave it at that
um okay i'll i'll leave it at that um
talk to me about mixed emotions that's a
very that's a very niche
um bipolar diagnostic
what does that mean to you
um so at the time i'm trying to dig back
because it's been two years now um
so at the time
it felt like
i could crawl out of my skin
um like i was so depressed and at the
same time like i was just shaking inside
my body so like so for the me that mixed
really
it
it kind of surprised me because i i
don't
i don't quite understand it you know
what i mean like i
hmm um
here's here's the way i've heard it
described is
um so for instance if you meet somebody
with bipolar and they're having a manic
episode
it's
in all honesty it's one of my favorite
people on earth to be around
there it's it's mayhem and it's chaos
and it is laughter and it is a thousand
miles an hour and the folks i've i've
that i'm in close relationship who have
bipolar manic faces they're one
i laugh so hard they're they're a it's
just it's a it's a it's a roller coaster
my understanding of
and this so rare that's what i'm asking
you is a mixed emotion would be
um somebody who is
oh let me back up somebody
with bipolar without mixed emotions they
are running high and it's this sense of
optimism this sense of i can take on the
world it is the sense of
i can do everything better than you and
in in my case they're right like they
can get stuff done in three days that it
would take me two weeks to do right
um that mixed emotions is their body is
running like that but their mind is
still super sad
their mind is still super depressed they
still they have no optimism they've got
no
um energy about accomplishment and what
we're going to do and we're going to
turn this core and then you and i are
going to get married and we're going to
go do this and this and this and this
it's not that their body's running that
fast but their heart and spirit is still
under the cover saying i just want this
to stop
yeah i don't know if it's ever been like
that before like it was mostly just like
um
like everything is so so so so bad
and i can't stop the world around me to
take a breath hmm
so i'm i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you my opinion and that's
okay it's gonna be worth what you're
paying for it okay
okay
um i do not like
at all
i do not like
somebody i don't like postpartum
diagnostics
and i don't mean postpartum not
postpartum depression as as in another
diagnostic but
somebody who is struggled for years of
infertility someone who's gone through
lots of trauma somebody who then has a
baby
and how was your how was your pregnancy
was it carefree and exciting
yeah it was it was just fine it was like
the depression like abated for a while
okay
and then your body goes through the what
just happened after the baby's born and
everybody experiences that different
that re-regulation the hormones the
what's life gonna be like your
relationship with your husband's
different he's got his trauma he's
dealing with and now he's got a little
kid and how's this gonna look and any
old stuff from your past is now coming
up and then his
and then just
tag somebody in the middle of that
with a diagnosis of a mental health
disorder
feels not right to me
well and the funny thing is is that um
i i found it out by accident she the
psychiatrist never told me she just
threw some pills at me and i went online
to take care of a bill on my
uh app for the hospital and i looked at
i just happened to look at my notes and
the diagnostic was on there and i had to
ask her like is this really what's going
on and she's like well yes
because
your dad is bipolar oh my gosh dude go
get another
so you're going to get me all fired up
and i'm going on vacation tomorrow so
listen i'm so sorry don't be sorry you
don't apologize for me nothing man i'm
on same team i want you to go get a
second opinion and i want you to walk
them through what happened okay okay
so how how far removed are you from your
initial diagnosis
um two years okay so bring me throw the
diagnosis put it in a drawer and let's
close that drawer
okay right now something is worrying you
about the way you are parenting the way
you are loving your husband the way
you're taking care of your family and
friends the way you're taking care of
yourself what about your environment now
what about you right now is making you
nervous to ask how do i protect my kid
and my marriage from me
um so
i feel like i'm not as emotionally
available as i should be
who told you you should be what
well
so like um
my husband was like i can never make you
happy and then
i just kind of translated that into like
i'm
i'm not showing him enough that i'm
happy and if i'm not
showing my emotions am i
hurting my family by like not
not showing them that that i'm okay with
with
our dynamics if that makes sense
so are you feeling joy at home and it's
just not demonstrative or are you
are you running pretty low are you
remembering back to high school when you
when you just ran low
um
it
i i feel like i'm fine inside and that
the world is like never like my
the people around me aren't seeing it
okay because they'll be like are you
having a bad day today what's wrong
today and i'm like i'm i'm fine i'm just
a resting witch face i don't know
whatever no you're not
so here's
i'm afraid that my daughter
will
not think that i love her because i'm
not showing her that i'm happy
um
okay and i think it's part of like what
i experienced like my dad emotionally
withdrew when he had his breakdown
and so i'm afraid that i'm doing that
now
so let's not be afraid let's let's speak
in in data points
okay are you withdrawing from your
daughter
um
they're
yeah
at some level because there'll be days
where i just
i can't i can't function that well and
i feel guilty about that yeah
are you withdrawn from your husband
i'm trying very hard not to okay
i'm like if i if i realize that i'm
doing it then i i
go and like give him a hug or touch his
face or there you go yeah you know like
scratches back or something like to
physically connect us
um but so cece can i ask you something
let me
children of somebody with true bipolar
disorder
they often will spend their life trying
to make sure everybody else is okay
because they had to
right
and
they become the broker of joy in the
house they become the peacemaker in the
house they become the
agent of safety in the house
and it's both exhausting and not their
job it is in that time but then that
same
over time it becomes not your job in
your workplace or in your marriage or
wherever
so let me ask you this
what do you need right now
you're doing a lot of thinking for other
people
yeah for sure what do you need
i need to just like relax
just let it go you know
don't hold it back anymore that was just
my frozen reference sorry
what do you want to let go
i want to let go like uh
like the responsibility i feel over
other people
but you have responsibility of your
daughter
well yeah
yeah
here's here's
all right here's my full recommendation
you ready
ready
the things you're describing to me
on a three minute phone call right or 10
minute phone call
um
sound a lot like an exhausted parent of
a two-year-old
sound like somebody who's married to
some
to somebody that she loves and y'all
have been through hell and back the last
five or six years and you've probably
kept running and kept running and kept
running and at some point that trauma
catches up with everybody
it sounds like a
new mom
who grew up in a disconnected home
and growing up in the home of somebody
with bipolar is chaotic and it's scary
and sometimes it's scary because that
person disappears and sometimes it's
scary because that person's sitting
right there and they're not even present
and was your mom married to him
yes yeah they stayed married through the
whole thing but it was
it was rocky
that's right so i want you to think in
terms of your body your body remembers
this story and it doesn't end well
and so what your body's trying to do is
protect you
from a story that it knows and what you
have to do is to teach your body
both through thinking and through how
you act
that you're safe now this is a new story
this is different
in some of that retraining your body
will come through partnership with a
psychiatrist if you have bipolar
disorder
some of that will come through marriage
counseling because your husband's going
to have his own trauma work to do too
he's had a lot of loss
and a he's been
in his head he's been propping up a
scared wife for five years or six years
or a heartbroken wife or an exhausted
wife or whatever right
and now you got a two-year-old and
you're looking at your relationship
saying what what do we do now
and it's all different
and when things get all different then
we start putting stories in each other's
heads
and his story is she doesn't like me
because if she liked me it would look
like this
and your story is
if i wasn't broken i would be acting
like that
and what i want you all to do is to go
see a good marriage counselor and say we
have a new baby we've been through a lot
of loss we've been through 2020 2021.
i've got to deal with my dad's stuff
you've got to deal with all the loss and
your dad's stuff
let's do this together and then you're
going to get some new tools and probably
neither of you have any sort of model
for what this will look like
fair
very fair yeah so here's what i want the
word i want you to keep in your head as
you move forward is curious not
judgmental
okay okay
listen to me closely you are not broken
your body's trying to take care of you
okay
thank you
do you you promise you hear me
yes okay
a psychiatrist or a counselor or a
mental health practitioner
should never
ever
secretly diagnose you with something
in order to throw pills at you or to get
some sort of insurance reimbursement if
somebody's going to tag you with a label
that will last forever
diagnostically
they should sit down and walk you
through what this means how y'all will
be in partnership together
as you learn new ways to live and to
love and to connect
and what role pharmaceuticals will play
and how short of a time it will that
will play they should they have should
have a heart of a teacher
they should not be
they should not have secrets
it's unethical it's nonsense
it's not a it's not a partnership you're
worth more than that that's what i'm
telling you okay cc
thank you
now you may go meet with psychiatrists
and they're like for sure bipolar for
sure okay
right and what that will mean is you're
going to sit down with a marriage
counselor and your husband and y'all are
going to walk through what does making
sure i take my medicine look like what
does making sure i move my body and i
take a bunch of
fish oil every single day even when i
don't want to what's it look like to
make sure i'm having skin-to-skin
contact with family members even on the
days i want to crawl under my blankets
and not come out
what's it look like the days you leave
me alone and let me have my day under
the blanket so i can come out strong the
next day
what does exercise look like when i
can't move my body
right that's when you get in that's what
creating a life worthy of living
we're like of worthy of having joy and
laughter and fun and and dealing with
bipolar
that's what that life looks like it's
intentionality it's about thoughts and
behaviors it's not about the diagnostic
the diagnostics part of life is what it
is what it is
you haven't convinced me you have
bipolar is what i'm saying and we've
only talked for 10 minutes so
i don't know you that well your husband
may be like for sure bipolar
um
i don't like this i don't like the way
the whole thing was done
it just feels gross to me
that you take somebody in the middle of
a mess and tag them forever i don't like
it
and i didn't go to med school so put
your mean notes in the in the in the
youtube comments
fun ruiners
but i do want you to go get a second
opinion you're worth that i do want you
and your husband to be curious about one
another and go to a marriage counselor
and say all right we got a new baby
we've had a lot of trauma we're in this
together for the long haul and so we're
gonna have to find new ways to talk to
each other new ways to be sexually
intimate together new ways to parent
because we've never seen it done right
before or not right we've never seen
that healthy before
we've got all this new stuff to learn
and i'm so glad i get to do it with you
and we're gonna figure this thing out
together so go see somebody make both of
those calls today make them both today
you're going to be on the road to
healing we'll be right back on the dr
john olympia show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to liz in
bangor maine what's up liz
hey there dr john how are you so good
what about you
i'm living the dream are you really
what's that like
well i mean nightmares can be dreams too
so
i work on a podcast with james
so what's it i'm just kidding i love it
i'm living my dream i'm moving my my bl
my best life
hey so what's up how can i help
so i have
a question for you um
how can i cultivate self-discipline when
it comes to eating
are you setting me up i'm the worst
person to answer this call
yeah i've been listening for a little
while so figured you might be one of the
best people so
i feel like you're making fun of me a
little bit liz but it's okay i'll go
with it i'll go with it all right come
tell me about your relationship with
food
well um i've always
struggled with my weight um starting
from the time i was probably a mid to
late teenager i've kind of just been
yo-yoing
um
okay stop right there really
what was
what's what started the relationship
with food when you're a teenager did
something happen
no i think it's just my metabolism
caught up with me and um i just ended up
gaining a bunch of weight and then um
i think
there might have been i don't know it's
just kind of happened
you kind of have been a little bit about
to say i mean i've always been a little
bit larger than everyone else but it
just kind of um
started catching up to me i guess okay
so and how old are you
i'm 28 28 now
okay and then so you've been yo-yoing
and then what
um well i am sick of yo-yoing and i'm
trying to figure out ways to like i'll
get on
like i'll be really disciplined for a
shorter amount of time
and then i'll get off the bandwagon and
like
i'll just gain all the weight that i
lost back and i can't i've been trying
to learn how to make sustainable
everyday
life changes that i can stick to because
you know i don't want to you know i'm
writing out my health in my 20s for sure
um and i'm not going to be in my 20s
forever and my health is going to catch
up to me
so
you like yourself
yes
tell me about that why do you like liz
because i'm adventurous and i'm fun and
i work hard
and
i
am a great
sister and daughter and friend
and employee and co-worker
so you told me a bunch of i don't have
self you told me a bunch of external
metrics those are great performances why
do you like liz
that's really you tell me a lot you told
me a lot of things liz does
especially for others what does liz do
for herself that she loves
um i work
i work hard
and i enjoy hiking
and backpacking i enjoy
spending time with my cat
and
i don't know
i'm a good i'm a student and i work hard
with that
do you have good character
i would say so yeah do you tell the
truth overall
mostly i mean mostly
um here's what i'm getting at i i always
want to know if when someone's got a a
challenging relationship with food
um
is it
truly between the food or is it a
defense mechanism
for something else going on
i started tracking
um i've done this several times in my
adult life i started tracking my
food
intake and particularly around food that
i know is unhealthy for me
and
a hundred percent
a hundred percent
of the times i mindlessly reach for
something whether it's chips or
ice cream or just
thinking tyler made his grandma's
cookies back here back in this
in the back studio here and
he was like i mean you just got to and i
did and
a hundred percent of the time
it's relational in nature or fatigue in
nature either i'm frustrated about
something i'm disconnected from somebody
my daughter just said a thing that for
some reason i decided to allow to hurt
my feelings my wife and i are off kilter
i'm frustrated with my son's math
teacher
um me and my boss are having
we're at odds
something relational in nature
it's it's a
unthinking i just go do
my body has learned this makes this
better for a minute
yeah
either that or the second one is i'm
exhausted
i'm so tired do either of those ring a
bell to you
um to an extent yes
if they don't it's all good that's just
the way
that's that's just me following the data
of my n equals one experiment with my
body
what about you yeah
um well i'm definitely
when you've talked in the past about you
know if there's a box of cookies open
and you just eat the entire thing um yes
i have that i have that problem
maybe not the gene to go with it who
knows but
i have that problem
i know that
sometimes when i'm stressed or when i
just haven't uh
eaten in a while i'll be much more
likely to stop by and go get some fast
food or something which i've been
curbing pretty good lately okay um
but um so here's what the data tells me
a couple of different things and they're
they're across the board and i want to
preface this with saying i'm not a
nutrition expert
and so i want to make sure i don't get
out over my skis here i'm going to talk
to you about stuff in my life okay and
the folks that i've walked alongside
the first thing this is relatively
recent i've talked about on the show
just a little bit um it made a lot of
sense to me
this idea of chronic stress that we are
running so hard and so fast and it's not
even so hard so fast relationally or at
work
we're in bodies that did not evolve to
drive 90 miles an hour to work among
other
2000 pound metal missiles that are
driving next to us
we're not designed for all of the
email clicks and the phone calls and the
text message we're just not designed for
all the assault of
um
marketing messages and you suck and you
should look like this and not that and
oh my gosh they're not your friend and
they didn't like my video and i don't
like them in the real world because they
didn't like me in my imaginary world
our
bodies
literally are not designed to live in
this world
and they've got crude response to stress
our body does fight flight
there's the fawning one which is which
is a different thing and freezing
what never occurred to me um gosh
james do you remember who this was it
huberman or atiyah one of these smart
guys they're way way way 10x 100x
smarter than i am
talking about
if your body
recognizes it's in fight or flight it is
going to reach for the cheapest energy
source possible
because it's in search of cheap calories
that it can burn for energy right now
because it thinks it's in a fight or
that it is sprinting for its life
and the cheapest calories we got are
cookies and chips
right um sugar-laden carbohydrates that
are going to help us get from a to b
what our
bodies don't know is that we're just
sitting on the couch watching netflix
we're watching somebody else getting
chased and murdered and but our body
sets off to try to defend ourselves
against somebody else's problems and if
we watch the news and scroll etc so
step number one is
nope it's not step number one i'm gonna
say step number two step number two is
look at the world you've created your
ecosystem
are you taking care of you
are you stressed a lot are you flying
around a lot are you busy a lot
because if you are it might be that your
body's trying to take care of you does
that ring a bell or no tell me i'm off
uh the stress uh like the always busy or
stressed yes okay in general
so the next part is something i got from
james clear
and
it rang more true to me than anything
else i've ever
i've ever read i've ever participated
and i've never ever internalized
and that's this
he wrote his book atomic habits i highly
recommend that people read that book
it's a great book but the biggest
takeaway for me from that book was this
most of us start
a weight loss goal a relationship with
food we start these things with a number
with a destination with a goal
and i know enough from the psychology
research is that these external metrics
these external things
are never sustainable because wherever
you end up
there you are right
so if you lose 20 pounds and you don't
like yourself you're gonna be 20 pounds
later and not like yourself if you find
yourself lonely and disconnected without
relationships and you lose 50 pounds
you're going to be lonely and lose 50
pounds and at some point your body's
going to solve that equilibrium
and it's going to try to it's going to
do what it can
to solve for that discomfort
and if you do drugs you do drugs if you
do food you do food if you work 90 hours
a week you work down here whatever you
pick your poison right
what james clear says to do is instead
of starting with i want to lose this
much weight
or i want to eat
never eat sugar again or something like
that
he said start with creating a new
identity
and i do this every year
like this is part of my annual routine i
just look at my life how have i been
doing how's my relationship
what are the identities i want to adopt
this year
and so instead of saying i want to lose
a bunch of weight or instead of saying i
want to be less heavy or less big or i
want to have a better relationship with
food instead of starting there
i start with this
i'm a guy who stewards his one precious
body
that's who i am
and from there i'm gonna backfill things
like people who
honor their bodies who are good stewards
of their bodies they don't eat that
trash
people who are who are honored and
steward their bodies go to bed they
don't watch netflix another show and
another show another show by the way i
was up to like 1 30 doing edits on my
book
and i ended up watching episode of the
office by the way it's the single
funniest episode it's in season eight i
didn't even remember it and i was
laughing so hard by myself at 2 am and i
was the whole time i'm thinking
what kind of
you have a show that you teach people
how to take care of themselves and i'm
up at 2 a.m watching tv you know what i
mean like um
so
start with an identity
so you like yourself and you should yeah
you're a good human being you're a great
woman and what do you do for a living
i work in ems
in ems
yeah on an ambulance
oh gosh
why didn't you lead with that
also
also deal with secondary traumatic
stress
good god almighty if you deal in other
people's trauma all day every day
your body is in fight or flight always
always
the number of times i left a wreck
and stopped at a gas station for just
some nonsense on the way home was a lot
right
yes i'll leave with that next time
so
here's here's the thing
i want you to spend some time this could
be writing it down it depends how far
you want to go i want you to write down
get a small little journal and write
down a couple of identities i'm somebody
who takes care of their body
i'm somebody who will show up to
somebody else's worst moment fully
present ready to rock and roll and so
since i'm that kind of person this is
what i have to do i have to
eat well i have to not eat nonsense like
that i'm gonna backfill those things the
numbers on the scale will take care of
themselves if we live into the identity
that we want to have
and here's the other the third big one
you have to have to have to have people
who walk alongside you can't do life by
yourself
okay
do you have a couple of drivers that
would
join you on some sort of reimagination
like dude we are team x and this is just
how we roll this is who we are
um
sure
they're all like screw you we're going
to mcdonald's forget it
they're not exactly the most supportive
when it comes to stuff and people bring
in goodies all day every day especially
around christmas because you know we
work at a fire department exactly the
worst they're the best and the worst ugh
i know
let's start with the identity piece
let's start with getting a small journal
and i want every time you reach for
something i want you to stop and go what
am i feeling right now
am i disconnected am i exhausted
am i stressed
begin to ask yourself that it may not be
at all and if it's not
then it becomes a much simpler
transition
most of us have to find the gap between
impulse and action
because if we can find that gap we can
pause in that gap and then do another
action that's how you take control of
your actions
okay and we do me one last favor
sure will you be so so
graceful with liz
because i know that you say you like her
i think there's sometimes you don't like
liz
or sometimes you get really pissed off
or ashamed of liz is that true
um
more so recently yes but this is more
chronic
here's the thing i don't fully believe
you i think you're hedging it but you're
on in front of a million people so i get
that too
listen i want you to be graceful with
liz
okay because liz is worthy of being
healthy
this is worthy of laughing a whole lot
she's worthy of
having a night where she just eats
garbage and gets up the next day and
goes again
she's also worthy of changing
everything
just because
just because
fair enough is that fair
i think so awesome remember one last
thing
your triggers
that's your roadmap
that's the gps towards getting well
so when you can identify those triggers
then you know to lean
man if you're having relationship
problems
now you know i got to go work on my
relationship problems if you're running
a doing a job that is high stress high
stress high stress high stress at some
point you go maybe this isn't the job
for me or i got to do it a different way
or in a different capacity at a
different place because my body's saying
that's enough
but whatever it is you're worth it liz
and dude i'm going to try i'm going to
try to take care of myself
ubn 2. we'll be right back to the doctor
john de luna show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan
200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we got one more call let's go
to michael in macon bacon georgia what's
up michael
dr john thank you for taking my call
this afternoon uh listen here's my
question i'm a pastor
dude are you a pastor you have a pastor
voice
how did you how did you get that
i have no idea so listen i grew up my
dad was in radio was in broadcast
journalism so
maybe i was supposed to be on the radio
and i wound up preaching but who knows
dude you sound way better at this than i
am
that's incredible man
all right so sorry i was about to
interrupt you
let me know are you are you a pastor man
for real that's incredible your voice
all right so what's up
so i had pastor here in in middle
georgia a little town called perry and
i'm working on my preaching plan for
next year and i'm working on a series of
messages
to address problematic emotions from a
biblical perspective like from the
gospel and so my question for you is
what are some what you would say best
resources
for research and for sermon prep might
even have some good application
to make this the scriptural applications
for my people
not a lot of people ask me for insights
to their sermons michael
well i'm not your adversary dr that's a
level of trust people don't don't
usually throw my way
uh well i read i read your book
redefining anxiety okay i listen to i
listen to your show regularly and um
i usually listen to you at one and a
half speed so you do sound good at one
and a half speed
but as i read through the book obviously
it starts with the you know with the
proverb right at the very beginning and
then you define the problem very clearly
and then bring the the application in
really well and so i thought you know
that that kind of resource is helpful
for a lay person such as myself who's
not necessarily obviously i'm not a
psychologist or psychiatrist or well
dealt in that so how do i help bring
those two worlds together and that's
where that practical application is is
needed it's helpful yeah it's so good
what a great question so
what i've noticed over the last 15 or 25
20 years i'll just leave it at 15 20
years
is
a temptation by pastors to
both the temptation and this weird
expectation
to become experts in everything
and
to have an opinion or to speak on
everything as though they are
at ground zero with those particular
things
and
now we've got pastors who are speaking
on all sorts of issues you know what i'm
talking about this is clearly not you
but it's other your colleagues for sure
not you
um
and so i think what a great place to
start when it comes to a discussion on
emotions a discussion on
what you say you want to talk about
emotions biblical emotions
yeah so i'm really
calling problematic emotions so things
like anxiety anger grief um a along a
long line so the i mean the reality of
pastoral ministry is that these are the
conversations and so i mean i do i do
pastoral counseling and i have a a
seminar and a post-seminary degree and
training and this kind of thing um
and so these are the conversations that
i have so from a from like a ministry
standpoint a lot of it is really we're
talking about is biblical discipleship
helping people to understand their
situation and see it in the in the
through the lens of the gospel right and
then some of that then some people need
to they they need more help they need to
spend time with um
with a trained uh counselor in that area
and that kind of thing so i'm not trying
to be more than i can be oh yeah yeah
gotcha got you guys but i know that
people are sitting in the in the in the
seats and these are the things that are
happening behind the closed doors at
home these are very good
that they that they have yet to be
willing to drag out in the light ah okay
okay
yeah so it kind of drives a lot from the
the pastoral side of the ministry yeah
um
you know we're so pastoring and
preaching come together and and meet
there um so that's that's that's where
it's really being driven from gotcha
so number one
i want to just applaud you for leading
your church through how can i help my
people live more peaceful lives how can
i let them
teach them to be better parents and
better spouses and better neighbors
um and that starts with dealing with
handling these emotions right where are
these things coming from what are they
about what i've found over the last year
working here at ramsey is
letting somebody know hey the reason
you're so raged out is because your
brain's trying to take care of you not
because of this thing on politics you
think is happening it's because this
thing over here is poking on you
it's giving people
right or
um one of my favorite
theological quotes of all time is from
rich mullins which is we often over
spiritualize jesus and i think there's
an incredible
an incredible
sermon series that can be done on the
human
the guy who
had his heart broken the guy who was
exhausted the guy who was
laying on on on his face saying the guy
who had doubt dad can we do it another
way i don't do it like this
the guy who then got up and went anyway
right so when it comes to emotions the
things that i want people to always know
is we live in a world and i'm trying to
do a third way here you may have heard
me say that
we live in a world that's either forget
your feelings forget your emotions get
over it quit being angry suck it up
or
we the other
swath of our culture is all about
your feelings are everything what do you
feel and if you don't feel loved or
happy or good then you do you and yolo
and all that right
right the third way is and i think it's
modeled biblically is
now you got to feel that stuff and then
go and then go do
and so what i always want to
i like to start with experts man
and not always
academic experts
but i love talking to somebody who might
be a marriage counselor i like my would
love my church to to hear those kind of
people i love getting um
genesis lessons from a biologist it's
awesome
it's a complete reframe right so if i'm
you i would look at a couple of core
emotions chip dodd's got some stuff out
there um henry cloud and townsend with
boundaries and stuff that there are some
problems that we can address and by
addressing those problems we end up
getting into the feelings and the
emotions part then we end up getting in
the how does that apply to me here's
what i mean
sometimes let's talk about being angry
it's easy to go i'm not angry i just
drive 95 miles an hour and dig my
fingernails into the
into my car right i'm not angry
sometimes
especially men we tend to to shy away
from our emotions
i love to come at things more
problem-based that's why we do this call
this show people might look on there and
say do i get nothing to learn from
somebody with bipolar disorder and we
get to the end and they're like oh gosh
i need to take control of fill in the
blank so similarly
if i'm doing a series on emotions i
might do a series on
how to be a better dad
because a part of being a better dad
means
pausing before i speak and feeling my
body as it gets angry and then asking
myself
surely it's not from a four-year-old
where is this anger coming from oh it's
lack of control it's fear it's that i'm
terrified it is whatever right
okay um i
how to be
less anxious
what's a biblical discussion of what
depression looks like
and i'm a firm believer with all my
heart
that the
science of mental health and the
neurology and all the neuroscience all
of that lines up
i mean you're talking about ancient
wisdom it all lines up
it's like the joke with us it's like
it's like the new old wisdom
it all lays on top of itself right so
there's nothing to be afraid of in fact
there's it's exciting for me i like
watching it when it lines up that way
so i'm going to start with problem this
is just me you start however you want i
mean if you want to talk about do a
whole series on feelings chip dad's got
a book out on
feelings that that's a good resource
just to walk people with the with i
think he's got seven core feelings some
have 15 core feelings some have five
whatever you can do that i just know in
my life i tend to go i'm not emotional
so i don't need this lesson it's not for
me i'll just play on my phone
but if you say hey how to be a better
husband i'll listen to you i'll give you
10 minutes on that and see if you can
convince me
or how to get a good night's sleep
you know you talk about the fruits of
the spirit is there anything more
peaceful
than a guy falling asleep on a boat when
everybody else is thinking they're going
to drown
like there's just a level right peace
there like what we don't even know what
that feels like man so
that's where i would look at it and then
reverse engineer it does that answer
your call i feel like i'm just rambling
at you now
no it it does it helps heals very much
um
so obviously in that opening you you've
got to you've got a hook you've got to
give them the reason that they say hey i
need to stay dialed in and listen to
what to what he has to say and what he's
sharing so that it's extremely helpful
the way you backed into that the other
thing is i want after people feel those
feelings i want them to demand evidence
from them is this true or is this not
true and if i can get somebody to demand
evidence instead of acting on that
feeling
the whole world changes
the whole world changes
if somebody cuts me off
and instead of flipping them off
grabbing my gun tailgating them somebody
cuts me off
and i
can pause and say what am i so mad about
and i go oh i don't
i don't i lack control here
i feel in the blank film like then i can
calm down and slow down man because tail
getting them is not going to do anything
but put me at greater risk than what
they just right so can i
just have a gap there and then on teach
people man i don't know what's happened
to you in the past
everybody i know has got garbage some
worse than others but we all have to
wake up today and say what are we going
to do today
right
and that's getting up the next day
after the garden and saying i don't want
to do this
and then saying
but i'll go
yeah you know what i mean like i
that guy didn't want to stop and
with the
the samaritan's want to stop and
wherever he was going and pay for that
dude's bills
but here i am and
now i get to choose what i do next
right and that to me becomes the message
you gotta
feel your feelings and then demand
evidence and then you gotta go do
whatever that looks like for you and if
i can help people walk through that then
the emotion stuff tends to work
themselves out man
okay that's excellent that's extremely
helpful to uh
to think that through right so i love
how you said that it helped them to feel
the feeling
and then demand evidence of their
feeling what's true what's real what's
really true
our feelings lie to us a lot
our feelings are just our body's way of
trying to communicate with us right and
our body if it can communicate that
we're gonna die
it will
get us out of a situation it will help
us fight a situation or help us free
it'll help us hide in a situation but it
keeps us alive and that's our body's job
our body's job is not to help us have
great marriages or to have good jobs
long term or to make good investment
decisions
body's jobs keep you alive
and man sometimes those feelings they
lie to us they over sensationalize they
over dramatize they whatever because the
body's trying to get a reaction out of
you
can i just feel that feeling and go
this is
crappy i mean i'm gonna seize in a
morning that hurts
and still i gotta go eat right
man she really hurt me just now
i'm still gonna empty the dishwasher
because that's what i said i would do
i mean if i if we can get people to do
that in our churches in our schools and
our communities we're talking about a
different planet right
yeah i think over the years
the church had not has not intentionally
meant to be this way but i think we've
we've probably simplified or not really
answered the questions that people are
asking and so because we don't know what
to say we just say simple platitudes
like well you know you just need to pray
about it not that prayer not the
discipline of prayer is not integral in
the spiritual growth and the the victory
that people have in this um
but they're they're they're dealing with
real feelings and really trying to live
you know monday through friday and and
do it well like ultimately you know life
is complicated and they're just trying
to get it right and so i feel like they
have questions and i'm just not certain
that we've really taken the time as the
church to answer them in a healthy way
that roots them back into the into the
scriptures i think we've just been
afraid
i think the church is afraid to to
address things that might get a little
messy to be honest with you i think the
church has as a whole has
absolutely
embarrassingly dismally
met the needs of their of the questions
people in their churches are asking i
think you're exactly right and it takes
a group of
brave pastors like yourself to lean in
and say what are y'all hurting with
we'll start there
yeah and man i'm telling you you get a
group of people
i think the same thing with our school
system man i think the same thing with
politic people are talking about what
are you talking about
i don't even know what that means you
know what i mean
right i i can't tell you the number of
times i've heard a sermon and i just
looked at my wife like what are you
talking about
i don't know what you're even saying or
i'm sitting in a in a
like a continuing ed program like
do you hear the words coming out of your
mouth it doesn't even make sense it's
just a platitude yeah on the top of a
plate you'd have a platitude
it's time that all of us get very
intentional about the real questions
people are asking
and well because those are real people
in the scriptures i mean jesus is real
and uh you know the gerson demoniac was
a real person and nicodemus was a real
person and zacchaeus was a real person
and david and goliath and you know peter
and paul all these they're they're
they're real people this is not like
aesop's fables or whatever and so there
are human emotions that are played out
as you've pointed out already that are
played out on the pages of the
scriptures in front of us
and so um i mean even jesus described as
he went from town to town he described
the people as
as harassed and helpless like sheep
without a shepherd i mean that was how
he first observed people you know when
he when he walked when he walked into
town and then he went to the business of
teaching
ministering and healing and bringing
healing so he you know he was he was not
just
dropping you know making mike drop
moments with his uh you know this
theology he was applying that in real
life and helping people right where they
were at and that's that's what we're
trying trying to do they also have some
conversation with people also he
got people water
right you know what i mean or he
talked to women when women weren't
supposed to be talked to he went into
situations that people said you
shouldn't be there
and he's like no this is where i'm at
right and so there's there's an action
to it there's a disruptive
um
there's a disruptive spirit i'm going to
be about loving people
and that means i'm going to get in the
mess and i'm going to get between
somebody trying to hurt you i'm going to
get i'm going to sit down on the ground
and draw on the dirt that's how close to
this thing i'm gonna get
and
yeah man
if if we get it you know
go ahead and say we know we're the
minister yeah we're demanding you know
to minister that grace and love of jesus
and it just can't be slung at uh from a
distance i mean now you have to step in
to
step into those lanes uh you know not
taking on i can't take on everybody's i
can't take on everybody's problems i did
that as a young pastor thinking that i
was no i fix everything
yeah you get fried and cooked and burned
out that's exactly right but that's
right and i took it all home and so um
but you still got to be able to step
into those lanes and meet people where
they're at that's exactly right and i
think i think a humility of a pastor to
say
i tonight or this morning i brought in
for 20 minutes of the 40 minutes
a first responder who's running the
street right now here's what our
neighborhoods look like
here's the fear this person feels
and then tying that back me let me we
learned through story jesus thought
through parables we learned through
narrative
um
i won't get down that road that's more
of a controversial road but
we learn through story we learn through
experience here as a teacher here's what
her world has been the last 24 months
so when you talk about anxiety this is
what this feels like when it talks about
carrying burdens here's what this
actually feels like and the more we can
make this stuff real the more we can
make these lessons not just so these
things that you sew on a pillow but a
way we treat each other the way we lean
into discomfort a way that we sit with
people on the margins of our society
dude you're talking everything
everything changes
everything changes and people just start
talking way way way way less
and loving and doing way way way more
so thank you so much for calling that
helps man
there's a reason nobody asked me
to preach
speaking of preaching
today's song of the day
i knew we were gonna go with this artist
i just couldn't figure out which hit we
were gonna use until i realized oh he
only had one
one
this one's for those my age and
listening
i might even tell you the name of the
song
it just goes like this
yo
vip
let's kick it
all right he says stop
collaborate and listen ice is back with
a brand new invention something grabs a
hold of me tightly and i flow like a
harpoon
daily and nightly will it ever stop yo i
don't know
turn off the lights and i'll glow
to the extreme i rock the mic like a
vandal i light up a stage and wax a
chump like a candle dance
go rush the speaker that booms i'm
killing your brain like a poisonous
mushroom
deadly
when i play a dope melody because
anything less than the best is a felony
love it or leave it you better gang way
you better hit bullseye james don't play
if you got a problem yo all salted
just check out the hook while james
child revolves it
see you soon